you might think of our following guest
is having a successful NFL career he
actually peaked in high school he once
ran for over 500 yards in a game he
rushed for 12,000 yards in his high
school career he's done some other
things he won a Heisman and led the NFL
in rushing blah blah blah but who cares
about that please welcome the pride of
you leave Florida Derek Henry
[Applause]
good to see you thanks for having me
how big is Yulee Florida this growing
small me growing up but it's a lot
bigger now okay you rushed for 12,000
yards yes sir what kind of competition
were you going against here Derrick
let's be honest see my school I think
when I got there was like it's been
there for like it had to be like six to
seven years so it wasn't like we were
scared of playing in competition but my
school wasn't that big so we had to go
out and ask schools to come play you
know but I mean like I'll just playing
some scrubs each and every week though
did you ever have a game where you
didn't get tackled
you probably have those in the NFL where
how would you explain what happened in
the last six seven weeks of the season
with with you in the offense and how you
guys kind of surprised a lot of people I
think we were just cooking on all
cylinders it was fun to be a part of it
someday you know you can build off of
you know definitely going in the right
direction you know thinking about how we
started off being two or four there was
definitely a lot a lot of positive a lot
of lot of momentum and a lot of good
things a bit of can you tell when you're
hurting somebody when you run
we're not playing I love you I don't
really look at it like that there were
guys who didn't want to tackle you this
year don't be humble like when I play I
promise when I play I'm not even like
like trying to see if they trying to
tackle or if anything else I'm focused
on what I need to do if you hit my way
have you ever heard a grown man whimper
trying to tackle you I heard grunts and
you know Chihuahuas Oh Jerome Bettis
told me he said he'd heard grown men
like I don't know what the knock was cuz
you didn't go in the first round I like
are you too tall at running back did
they look at you and go well he's 6-3
like we do this all the time we profile
quarterbacks and go you're not tall
enough like I I always wondered about
that when we saw you after you won the
Heisman Oh huh but what was the knock
against you um I think I mean era
Dickens to us all but I think it was
like the stigma on me that you know I
was tall I didn't have no quickness I
couldn't catch I couldn't block I went
to Alabama the back zone last I had too
much wear and tear and you know that's a
lot of baggage there yeah yeah I mean it
was a lot so but at the same time I knew
long as I got in and got on the team
that you know that value me and that
would use me and eventually I'll show my
worth in that's what I did who did you
will look up to growing up as a player I
can go on and on a list of did you have
posters on your wall not process but I
had like I had
I love the damn Thomson you know you
want my size I just I go Eddie did you
did you meet LaDainian I met Dana here
and it was like Kobe Bryant every Dana
Thomason where my heroes gonna did you
meet Kobe it's so funny I was just
talking about this with the other days
assistant we're at the ESPYs but was my
well my work here I was I was well yeah
I thought got drafted and I'm Kobe was
walking up here and all Black Hills with
his wife and I was like there's Kobe
what should I say so I kill accent she
was like this this is just be yourself
this like what you don't know me what if
you don't
she knows who you are and he walks by
and I just froze the first time I
couldn't say anything
what would you said I don't even know
that's why I've been carrying the
Heisman with you that would help maybe
that would help that would have like a
sticker on me a big ol stick of my
jacket your jersey on what was I
thinking and I don't know if you thought
that when you saw the news of you did
have that chance to say hello
all time stuff went to my head I'm still
messed up to it I had a Tracy I've been
wearing a dress for the pastor I slept
in his jersey other than I that's like
that's like my all-time favorite athlete
all the time that's like but what was it
in Kobe that you just that I mean he was
not a football player it's not football
I think just the way his dedication to
the game just the way he plays you know
he inspired me as a kid this there's
everything like it just it was like
having like having like a hero you know
saying people talk about when people
talk about Michael Jordan that's how I
seen Kobe that was that was my Michael
Jordan so you know anytime anybody say
anything about Kobe you guys anybody
I'm going to bet all the way down so
that was like man I can't even I can't
even put no worries like how I felt when
I got the news I was at the Pro Bowl
nothing locker room and I didn't even
believe I was like what like no and I
mean then somebody came in to me and say
they confirmed me and I was just torn
still torn Thursday prayers out to his
family and all the families that
involved yeah a lot of people a lot of
the people that I've spoken to who were
younger under the age of 40 say that's
that's our Jordan yes that definitely
definitely is man it's just I just thank
him for what the all the things he
showed far as being an athlete
everything that he represented you know
everything that he's done for the game
not just basketball just all over up
there the impact he had on athletes I
think people seen it from know what
everybody said
each and every sport like you know it's
just he meant so much to a lot of people
he definitely meant a lot to me you know
you know the years that he played that's
one thing I'll never forget never forget
he's Derek Henry the Titans running back
joining us on behalf of FedEx the air
and ground NFL players of the Year
awards
let me hear you be a spokesperson here
yeah so I'm here on behalf of FedEx for
the air and ground Player of the Year
you can vote on nfl.com slash FedEx or
you can vote on NFL Twitter voting ends
at 3:00 p.m. so make sure you vote for
air and ground and FedEx is doing a
great job by donating twenty thousand
dollars each on behalf of each winner
air-ground winner as the great thing
FedEx is doing I'm glad to be here I'll
never have look at you you were looking
at the camera while you were doing that
and you were communications major right
I do a little research
you think you could host this show yeah
I could I'm easy now easy now one thing
to beat the page in there's one thing to
beat the Ravens it's a little different
when you sit over here I heard that yeah
go so if I said you you could do this
show your dream guess I'm gonna give you
a three guest that you can have on who
are you gonna have on uh three guests
yep I wanna know Danny Thomas in and one
more Jordan oh by the drawer have you
met Mike I have not met Michael joy I
want to meet Michael joy well you
wouldn't say anything to him if you met
him at basketball player do you think
would have made a great football player
Oh
LeBron you think LeBron yes LeBron
and I know uh Ireson was good at
football too actually yeah
he's gonna put about two but I think
LeBron yes there's a physical specimen I
think Iverson might have been as good at
quarterback as Michael Vick yeah they
talk about how I see my doctor in here
too so yeah LeBron tight in LeBron tight
in receiver he probably do is just as
much as he doing no basketball to
football just because he was an
all-state wide receiver yeah so yeah
probably I'll say receiver tight ear if
I had you play one-on-one against LeBron
you were you're a high school basketball
player well yeah yeah how do you think
you could you score on the brunt
yes definitely really yes you're only
six three yes I mean six threes brig
poly bring out LeBron James here you
bring them out here at 6:30
whoa you want a piece of it yeah yes but
you're six three that's tall in the NFL
well who couldn't say they scored on
LeBron James everyday they might even
say that I'm a scorer
I'm gonna have that title I scored on
LeBron James you really yes okay I mean
I believe you could you score LeBron
James I would want the opportunity to
score when I was your age but I would
want a piece of Michael Jordan to we're
competitive oh absolutely
yes are you officially a free agent a
free agent yep okay so when you get to
talk to everybody uh things is it March
okay there March but hopefully I don't
have to do that I can be in Tennessee
are you planning on being intense yep
did you rent or buy in Tennessee by you
did buy yeah okay well it's a pretty
good market if you have to sell though
if I said you could be one other uniform
do you think you look you'd look good in
two-tone blue I'm thinking now I got a
couple of I got a couple of suggestions
for you okay
the Dolphins two-tone blue but I'm
getting some blue in there I'm blue the
Dolphins got that that aqua
you mean those Titan uniforms look good
and those aren't good-looking
[Music]
Cowboys pretty badass Saints those
Saints white jerseys that does plane
genies plane so I got you see dolphins
Steelers I could see with the Steelers
how about that could you see yourself
for the Steelers you got black and gold
panceliss Franco wrong no more lady on
bail and got you wrong in there oh oh
boy James Conner James Conner nice
complement to you Robbo back yes he'd be
a nice complement to you I think he's
only done pretty well there so you don't
want to go to Pittsburgh no I think Jane
kind of he's he's got it um let me see
Paulie you're taking out your money
you're trying to get him to go to the
Bears a Bears fan I got $27 on me and
they'll pick up the rest call winning
Montgomery I think I've seen you play so
you don't want to play in cold weather I
don't know what it is okay football cold
cash is what you want you like him love
them okay
cuz if you need me I'm here okay I'll
sing the praises yeah we when we want
I'm a closer
[Music]
like Aaron Rodgers you know his TV agent
I'm not like that guy sue and all you
know it's not my dorm sue no suit no no
I don't know
no no no my business is when my guy is
on the field that's business when I go
in there let's talk and then I'm gonna
send him out and let him go that's all
it is
all right we're thunder and lightning
let's do it
the FedEx air and ground NFL players of
the Year awards you can still be voting
today voting closes at 3:00 p.m. Eastern
today yeah
just letting you know Volvo yeah you can
nfl.com / FedEx in the NFL Twitter page
would you let Paulie put on the helmet
and you'd just smack him around give him
a little stiff arm if he wants to
what's that pressure know he wants to
know he took on who Matt Forte Clay
Matthews like all of these guys he
wasn't afraid it's just like you against
LeBron you know I mean you can put it
I'm not gonna be to two crazies I'm not
gonna be to go yeah yeah yeah just a
playful stiff arm
pray for me yeah don't hey it's great to
see you in there all right we'll take a
break we'll come back after this close
up shop in the Dan Patrick field for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR Live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]